welcome to find your spice today this is
all about storytelling we're going to my
background actually is in filmmaking
which is all about telling stories and
what I wanted to do is sort of give you
some of the clues as to how to best tell
your story with that dread question of
tell me about yourself which is the
answer they want is not for you to
regurgitate something on your resume of
course the answer is they want to get a
sense of your character and what your
story is about and stories have a lot of
the same elements to them and they've
had the same elements to them forever
just a little background about myself my
name is Andrea Mia and I live in
Portland Oregon I've been doing coaching
for years mainly focused on creative
people and with MBAs as I said my
background was in filmmaking for a long
time and I'm still involved in that
industry to some degree and but I'm
really interested in helping people help
tell their stories and and feel good and
confident about them as well and that's
it's not just it's not enough to just
tell it it's also important that you
feel good about it okay so and I am not
terribly savvy at doing these webinars
yet so today's agenda
welcome everybody first of all and I
just want to make sure
you're all in now I just you know
mention on chat whether you can hear
everything and everything's okay
I see you Manish thank you
okay good I don't know if you just heard
what I just had to say let me know if
you just heard my introduction
okay not sure anyway okay good I'm glad
okay yes I did okay thank you Maggie um
anyway so today's agenda we're gonna
talk about the elements that go into
what makes a good story what makes any
story basically actually hold together
and originally these elements that you
see on the screen here today were broken
down by Aristotle which is around 384
BCE so around was 2500 years ago or so
and he was looking at storytelling as
far as poetry or dramas go but this same
basic structure as well as elements are
what week goes into telling a story
today and those are as I say here plot
which you have some sense of I'm sure
decor character which we'll go into a
little bit more this is the agenda for
today tell you tell your first story
we're gonna have a breakout session and
I'll have you tell a story to each other
and then we'll learn a little bit more
about storytelling and do that again
later
melody diction spectacle theme and then
we'll do another tell your story and
then a question and answer section and
closing comments
ah let's see okay so plot plot is
probably the thing that you're most
familiar with the idea of a beginning a
middle and an end
so we have to come from somewhere we
have to have some sort of drama
some sort of conflict some sort of
exposition something has to happen in
some way and then we have to resolve it
those are the three things what airsoft
talks about is that we have to have some
sort of empathy basically for each other
establish that empathy has show what the
conflict is and then have a catharsis
catharsis meaning a resolution to it a
really simple idea of this could be I I
love going shopping I went to the store
the other day there were these homeless
people outside and they were making a
real ruckus and it was really disturbing
to me luckily somebody came out of the
store and asked them to be quiet and to
move their business on and I felt much
relieved
so this establishes where I am what I
was going to do where the conflict was
and what the resolution was so the
catharsis was the resolution I felt
better the the conflict moved on this is
just a really simple story in that way
so that's what plot flawed is you know
how is this relevant to you telling your
story this is part of how we think we
want to have a resolution to it so if
you tell a story where there is no
resolution like I joined Udacity to take
a class
okay where did that go that that didn't
really give me much of a story that
didn't tell me much I wanted to learn
all about machine learning I joined
Udacity because I wanted to learn all
about machine learning you see my
background is in engineering and I love
problem-solving more than anything this
class at Udacity has taught me how to
problem-solve on a new level I am now
able to problem-solve using a certain
type of language sorry I'm not going to
but which language right now
a certain type of language and it's
really exciting to me because I'm able
to do this problem-solving on a
different level
so what that's doing storytelling wise
is it's telling me a little bit of why
and and what's what's interesting to me
about this
taking this class basically it's not
giving much of a plot it's not giving
much of a background so I want to
introduce a couple of other ideas as to
what we do next
so decor second idea has its decor decor
in this case is sort of where where you
are coming from so I have little
examples here does anybody recognize any
of these places at all you can write
down in the chat if you do
does anybody recognize anything
let's see let me just make sure
everybody can get into the room
realizing that I think everybody's in
the room oh now okay
tower exactly so that's in in France we
have Machu Picchu in Egypt we have the
Colosseum area we have Santorini New
York lots of different places actually I
was just having fun
showing the all of these places have
evoke different things and maybe you're
from Myanmar dye the picture of me amar
down there or I have Brooklyn and Wadi
Rum mentioned all of these different
good job Angkor Wat yep and the London
Eye and I think I have Versailles in
there as well anyway the ideas if you
give people a context of where you're
coming from not just necessarily a city
but maybe you're from a small town maybe
you are from a family of Engineers
yourself it could be what your family is
from it could be the place you are from
it could be the background that you are
from like I moved around a lot growing
up and therefore studying for example
online is second nature to me
because that's how I grew up giving
people and it could be anything that's
what I'm saying but but what I'm the key
to it is giving them a bit of context
what he calls it as decor it's in a way
it's about dressing the background where
did you come from that answer does not
have to be the physical place it can be
how where you come from in your family
where you come from in your background
in some sort of fashion but you want to
give people a little bit of sense of
your background this is part of telling
your story
the third thing I want to bring up is
character there are two types of
character look yeah let's see that it
doesn't move um dynamic character or
round character so dynamic character as
you can read is a person who transforms
in some way a person who I may have
started here but now I am here or
because I learned this now I am doing
that there it's a there's a progression
basically of thought in trying to
communicate with somebody about yourself
it's almost like pinpointing that moment
when I knew that something was happening
that's a dynamic character one that has
could be could be very subtle but it is
transformational basically and an
awareness of transformation going on
that's one type of person's basic
character a person who becomes aware the
other type of character is a rounded
character very distinct personalities
backgrounds or motives like I described
before a person who loves
problem-solving more than anything in
fact comes from a family of puzzlers
this gives a sense of background this
tells you this is a rounded person and
this is a person who knows already what
they're all about
there is no I'm not making judgment on
either type of these characters okay but
what I'm saying is it's one thing that
you need to do is start to identify
yourself as one of these characters are
you a transformational character or are
you a rounded character
so is the essence of your story a story
about evolving or is it a story about
knowing from the get-go this is what I
am this is what I like doing for example
if you're a marketing person if
marketing for you is all about shaking
hands meeting people you are an outgoing
gregarious person period that's probably
how you were born that's probably what
you are that's what you like doing more
than anything your transformational
story might not be that striking maybe
it is but I'm trying to give an extreme
example somebody who really likes
meeting people pressing the flesh going
out of the way to do presentations to to
be in front of people at all time you
think actors maybe that that may be part
of what they're about to some degree um
that is a round character a person who
sort of stands in the world and has
known in a sense who they are the whole
time a transformational character is one
that has learned over time then and sort
of caught on to certain things about
themselves because maybe a certain event
has happened it doesn't have to be a
traumatic event but maybe something has
happened that has taught them something
about themselves and they have
transformed into a certain type of
person that likes puzzles for example or
maybe loves marketing and loves going
out there but they turned into that sort
of person so two different types of any
any questions about that on chat you can
put in
you
as these might be complicated ideas and
so I just want to make sure you're
you're getting them okay okay so what I
want to do now is I want us to actually
practice telling our stories there's
going to be more information that I'm
going to give you and more ways to round
out this story but this is this is the
idea there's only about 14 of you so I
guess we'll have probably just a couple
of breakout sessions basically and so
you're going to be able to talk to each
other so I whether it'll be groups of
four or not I think it just depends on
how many people we have so it may be
three or four groups what I would like
you to do is to introduce yourself to
each other and in your introduction I
want you to say who you are where you're
from how you first heard about Udacity
and what kind of class you're taking
there if you can add information as to
in the Y as to what led you there to
take it that it really becomes a story
in the sense how I got here and what it
is I'm hoping to get out of the class
for example so how I got here has to do
with your background and has to do with
your character is this something are you
transforming or is this I take classes
and this is part of what I do I take
this type of class and this is just the
next one that I'm taking because this is
who I am
those are the sorts of things I would
like you to try to share with each other
and when you listen to each other if you
can take little notes as to what it is
you've heard like what stuck out about
the other person's story okay what you
remember from it um it may be their name
it may be where they're from it may be
why they're taking the classes who knows
we don't know or maybe just a word or it
may be something about the quality of
their voice we don't know exactly what
it is that you're gonna tap into
but write down what it is your
impression is of each other when you
introduce each other okay so that you
can remember and now I'm going to try to
set you into breakout room so give me
one second
okay I'm not assigning you okay I'm
assigning you
okay so Emily
let's see
hmm sorry give me one moment here so
join the breakout room and
it seems there's a breakout room and
progress are any of you in the breakout
room
you
no no no okay interesting let's try it
again
you
unassigned okay Emily okay let's do a
sign to Brigham
okay actually because there's so few of
you today on this lovely Sunday I'm
actually going to put all of you in the
same room
hopefully this works are you all in a
room together now
you
I always introduce a so I started I
learned about Udacity when I want to be
I thought I wanted to be a scientist
although I wasn't quite sure what that
pet Udacity challenge last and it was
very good after going for the nanodegree
I realized I didn't want to be a data
scientist I want to be a data engineer
now that I'm learning about what the
differences so now I'm thinking about
DevOps so to gather more skills with
some what they did to me that's me so
dynamic versus round
I think I'm around character dynamically
looking for myself
does that count great Jamie can you go
yeah so I am I just the Udacity I'm
enrolled in the react program um I chose
the program because I want to
I heard by Udacity mice was searching
online for programs to UM help me
continue to grow as a developer and
learn new skills and it really it really
helped me with my programming skills and
I'm having a challenge it challenges me
and I'm having fun with
okay thank you that wasn't good you know
something this is about this is about
practicing it and listening to others
and then hearing oh I'd really like that
and and getting a sense of the better
selling in that sense so let's try Magda
next and I may have missed you in money
I'm not sure but Magda hi yeah thank you
I heard about you the city is through
I'm currently living in Germany well I'm
originally from Hungary and so I'm just
background I moved from the from the big
cities so the capital from Hungary to a
very small village where like 40 people
lives so it was a big change and work
working actually in the film industry as
well and working at home as a freelancer
and yeah I heard about that last window
of course and that was the trigger and I
said okay I would like to change a
little bit
probably a career change as well or just
widen my knowledge and that's why I took
the dynami is scholarship so that data
track and scholarship and yeah what else
yeah I think I'm more transform because
I if I look back my career I I try to
learn always something new and even I am
working in the same industry for the
last two decades I'm always try to find
something new which challenged me and
this is definitely a challenge for me at
the moment because of the programming
language this totally new I'm I'm
totally a newbie but I like this
challenge and of course the community
fantastic
definitely write down what you heard
from Magda as the takeaway of her
transformation okay because she goes to
one of the other points
bring up a thematic later which she too
didn't you Amane hi I'm Aiman I'm from
Morocco I work in the automotive
industry I heard about Udacity where I
was looking for
papers about the automotive the
autonomous driving systems and so I just
found myself in the blog of someone that
is now that lunch is the self-driving
nanodegree and I talked to him I could
accident LinkedIn I talked to him and he
introduced me to Udacity and fast
forward forward I wanted to get there
but I figure out that I don't have the
coding skills so now I'm started
starting from the very beginning
programming skills and yeah and I'm
going there so I think I'm very dynamic
because I've been doing a lot of things
during in my career and I'm very excited
about these self-driving field ok great
thank you very much i smart
can you hear me yes so I'm illest rain
north of Brazil and I heard about that
Sara
Nikki two years ago you know Sona as me
about my sister marketing on a degree
and I took these non-degree was my first
course experience with audacity and now
I heard about this that as my
scholarship you know I was interested
because I was i my daily life I worked
with data but not a never-before work
with his like tools like with
programming in daraa be easy so deeply
like this so this was the connection so
materialized I think I'm a very dynamic
it's who becomes an excuse to learn and
apply new stuffs to my daily job and I
work for the government here in the
state government and we I'm I'm a power
ability and the manager development
projects for their rural communities in
the states of the path okay wonderful
Emily and Jocelyn I don't see you your
faces but Emily can you unmute yourself
and introduce yeah I'm here hi I'm Emily
I live in the Chicago area and I was
introduced to Udacity programs from a
former alumni and I really developed an
interest in data as I worked in the
sports industry for the last decade and
just really used Udacity to develop my
programming skills with Python and I
hope to use data you know to better
companies and industries in the future
and taking their data from the past and
how that can help them to move on
okay good and jostling
hi now we can hear you hello hi hi I am
from Caracas Venezuela and I am a senior
and I heard about Udacity a couple years
ago when I'm try to to compliment my
courses from college to more technical
skills that I'm sorry I am a scholar
from
bertelsmann a scholarship and I am doing
the artificial intelligence and at a
degree I think I am as I I don't
remember her name I forgotten her name
but the lady from Germany said that I
think Matthew Mac sorry I think I am
transforming person because I always try
to learn something new all the here in
college I we are a little bit step back
from another universities from our
general United States or any other any
other countries I try to buy through
online and tried to complement my
education and always try to learn
something new
in order to get an a better job in the
future after my graduation thank you
that's fine
no that's no it's good I got something
out of that and I learned something
about you at least MMP who's just joined
us I'm not quite sure if you can unmute
yourself or know what we're doing
exactly but we're introducing ourselves
and saying why we joined Udacity
and if they're not going to unmute
themselves we'll move on actually since
we're in this room right now I'd like to
to do one thing I'm going to ask each of
you who you remembered and one thing you
remembered about them okay so I asked
you to take notes on everybody but I
just the one that's stuck out to you so
Jamie I'll start with you of all the
people that just introduced your set
themselves what's stuck out in your mind
it could be one word basically about one
person that's all we're not trying to
judge in any way we're just saying okay
what's stuck out
um okay so um I would say Lia the first
person who spoke um she she was in data
science before she like she was previous
and rolled on Udacity mm-hmm okay okay
smarter what do you remember
I got the one another less mister the
gopher Venezuela now sheets come about
that's it that's it that's fine that's
fine
I'm well it will do a few more magdi
what do you remember can I say two
because one of the person I remember
well because we are in the same track it
is lisman and he is one of the student
leaders and it was nice to to see him
again here so I am but the next one was
actually joseline for me as well because
she's she's a student from from
Venezuela and yeah she's she's learning
artificial intelligence with the
Bertelsmann scholarship so it is
something for me outstanding that the
student students learning something yeah
yeah and from South America as well yeah
and obviously or the other so I have
from from everywhere that's okay just
one right now Lea what success sticks
out to you
Oh unmute yourself Illya we can't hear
you
they're Maggie stuck out the most to me
because she went from a big town to a
small town and I would like to talk to
her more someday maybe because I had the
same experience I went from a large town
I now I am in a very small town which
has its challenges yeah very nice Emily
you may not have heard a lot of the
stories I'm not sure yes I was gonna say
I remember to Leah's story because she
was debating between you know data
science and being data engineer and
that's something that I've done a lot of
research on myself also excellent and
let's see Jocelyn what what do you
remember most
I'm Magda story because she she said she
always try to learn something new of
this she we have more than 20 years of
experience so she always tried to learn
something here that for me is very
valuable excellent and then money have
you heard any of the stories did you I
don't think you shared I'm not quite
sure
yes I did I did okay so it's for me it's
Magda as well but it's before because my
boyfriend has the same stories from
Hungary moved to Germany so it's stuck
in my head
so what's interesting about this for all
of us is that what you latch on to
basically what part of the story you
latched on to I asked you all to tell
the same story basically who you are
where you're from a little bit so the
where you're from part and interestingly
that's part of what stuck out to people
a lot is where you're from and where
you're from also went to where you're
from intellectually where where you're
changing from intellectually and what
you're learning so the names go away
oftentimes nobody commented on the
backgrounds yet but we haven't focused
on that and like what what we're seeing
picture was because that could play a
role and and it's interesting that you
know very little of what you say really
connects in the end and that's one thing
I want you all to know about the
succinctness of how you introduce
yourself is kind of important because we
take away whatever it is that we latch
on to and relate to the best that's what
we take away so we've got to give people
information to latch on to we it has to
be descriptive enough but it also has to
be succinctly rahl smart we all catch on
pretty quickly basically as soon as you
start to describe what it is
I think Magdi did a good description of
coming from a large town to a small town
and leaving it at that move from Hungary
to Germany large town to small town
interesting challenges 20 years in the
film industry also and keep learning
it's like what what does it boil down to
is is part of it and that's our take
away so I'm gonna get us out of the
breakout sessions we'll come back to
this in a moment I want to go over a few
more elements and then we will try this
again given given these other elements
let's
okay
you
[Music]
and there you are Newt hi you can hear
what I'm saying okay so like what I was
thinking about was I you can see the
screen right melody and prosody melody
and prosody that's about the sound of
how we speak what the music is in a
language you are a speaker of English as
mute yourself please if thank you um
when you are a speaker of a second
language this is one of the most
difficult things to to get basically and
not to speak in a monotone voice for
example but the way that you speak the
volume how you emphasize things your
personal like what the what your voice
really sounds like that tells a story as
well often times it sells a story of
confidence or no confidence to give you
an example of what can come across it
also gives you a sense of whether the
person is comfortable in the language or
not but melody is part of how we speak
to each other and it's part of the
impression that we give so like a
handshake or a proper bow when you meet
somebody
language the the melody of how you speak
speaks about you as well
and so if we are conscious about this
and we speak from our diaphragm and we
have confidence when we speak and we
listen to ourselves even on recording
and hear what we sound like
and make sure what we're not speaking
from here for example and and doing
breathy voice type speaking that can
make a difference on the impression in
the story that you're telling it tells a
different story basically at the end of
the day if I say I'm the most confident
person imaginable it's hearing me and
I'm not
I'm taking very large pauses as I speak
I'm not giving the impression of any
sort of confidence
okay I'm doing an extreme example but
this is this is kind of an important
thing about telling your story is
actually what the music is of your voice
another element is diction word choice
and clarity so clarity is about making
the ideas clear also okay choosing words
that are evocative in some fashion that
are simple enough for the listener to
understand and to get a feeling up
that's part of the listening exercise I
had you just do what stuck out you know
what words really hit home that you
really heard that she was a jaw Celyn
was from Venezuela like everybody sort
of got that one or a lot of you got that
one it's like oh then somehow that stuck
out in my mind is interesting and she
was a scholarship student she could have
chosen other words I'm from South
America not very descriptive didn't tell
me much about like which place in South
America or that maybe that Spanish is
her her native tongue could have been
Portuguese could have been licensed you
know we don't know so word choice
choosing your words carefully making
some I some decisions even before you
introduce yourself and tell that story
of who are you
choosing words that you know that they
will understand that are evocative in
some sort of way and that clearly tell
your story this is another aspect of
storytelling
so spectacle spectacle in this case is
when we look at each other a lot of you
have turned your videos off right now so
I can't do this to you right now but in
monetary something because we cannot see
you can't see any of this Oh lovely
no aren't seeing my beautiful pictures
give me one second
okay give me a moment here I think I
have to close this down I'm not quite
sure
technologically speaking I am a mess
with this unfortunately
let's see let's put this over here
give me one more second
[Music]
okay I cannot share thank you for
letting me know I
can't see right now where to share
although I think it's recording it
okay so what I was trying to share
and let's just see if let me try one
more thing give me one more moment
in here share
okay can you see a picture now
yes yes you can't okay and I'm sorry
it's not full screen right now but
that's okay
okay so spectacle is what what I had
just shared that you did not see were
melody and prosody that was what I was
talking about the music of language
basically and making sure that we in
turn ate well and and speak clearly
meaning our voices are strong and
clarity of word choice was the other
thing the last thing I want to share
with these pictures was spectacle
spectacle has to do with how we're
presenting ourselves physically how we
present ourselves physically in the
world tells some sort of story and we're
making some sort of choices about how we
what people are going to perceive about
us so I put some pictures here these are
all actually engineers on the bottom
right here these are all well-known
engineers in some sort of fashion
professors and Dean's etc and these are
all their professional photographs and
it's not that they're so formal
but you get some information from all of
them and how they are dressed and the
one thing I just want to end and I'm
showing you this picture of this guy
who's a doctor and also asked happens to
be a tattoo enthusiast let's say is that
how you present yourself physically also
tells part of your story
you can make choices within that one of
the more important things when you're
meeting people of course is do you smell
neutrally you know do you not smell
distinctively let's say I'm not over
perfumed or over food or over whatever
okay but neutrally so you're not telling
a story about what you had for lunch
you're letting them see you first
basically and not smell you first
they're also you don't want to have
clothing on that's going to tell a story
that you don't want to tell so if their
story that you don't want to tell is I'm
a really sloppy person then do you don't
dress like a sloppy person if you do
want to tell the story I am a sloppy
person then dress dress sloppy but those
are choices basically and they
communicate to anybody else in the room
part of what you're trying to say about
yourself the last one I want to share is
actually probably the most difficult to
figure out the most important because it
is the takeaway that people can really
understand you from and that is your
theme so when I tell a story I want to
know deep down what is it about is it a
story of optimism for example so I could
say the story the the conference was in
full swing with scholars delivering
knowledgeable lectures on varying
subjects in the end the audience enjoyed
it immensely
what is the thematic of that the
thematic is sort of a one of optimism in
some way the conference was going on
everybody was being delivered
knowledgeable information and the
audience was fully engaged
I'm looking at this optimistically
basically if I was to it
assign a theme to it in my life I would
say that part of my story is about
transformation I have gone from I've had
maybe I would say three careers in my
life all of them deep down are about
teaching and about sharing with others
and learning from people all around the
world the thematic has something to do
with sharing the and that I want to do
that and that I want to learn from
people from all over the place for each
of you if you boil down how you engage
in activities why you engage in
activities and what is the commonality
of those either engagements or the
activities themselves you can figure out
what the ongoing theme is of your life
are you a person there was one person
I'm not sure who it is now who likes
taking classes they just like taking
classes I didn't take perfect notes when
I was I was listening they like taking
classes and they keep doing that they
may be a lifelong learner that may be
part of the thematics of their lives or
a lifelong Challenger that they like
challenging themselves if there's
something that they don't know they want
to take a class they want to figure it
out so I'd like you to take a moment to
think about that for yourselves as well
what might be the thematic that
integrates the different things that you
have done in your life together
if you can deliver that to somebody in a
hi nice to meet you you know tell me
about yourself if you can tell them that
that that's probably the thing they'll
remember more than anything I'm from
Caracas and I'm a lifelong learner in
fact I get scholarships a lot of the
time to to study because I'm really good
at it as well and I'm really good at
integrating what I study into what I do
workwise
um that awareness and putting it up
front helps people remember who you are
and what your story is about
so
what I would see you can still see this
there so what I would like to do now is
I'd like this to join in one more time
and I would like us to tell the story
not of why you joined audacity okay but
think about what was the most striking
thing that happened to you in 2019 to
your family or to you think about when
you tell this story how this might tie
into your thematic what it is about you
that makes you different think about
also what it how it ties into your
character and also when you're telling
the story think about the plot think
about what is the beginning middle and
end of this little story that I want to
share about the most memorable thing
that happened in 2019 give us a little
bit of context you know so that's the
the background or where you're from
type art a little bit of context okay
don't spend a lot of time in that and
remember that your voice carries and
tells part of the story as well and with
English as a second language totally
fine to say you know take the pauses
that you need to take but when you speak
make sure to speak up so that we can
hear you well okay
take your time though and for when
English is not the the issue at all
remember also that the melody of how you
speak communicates something about your
story as well is this a story that's
upsetting is this a story that's really
exciting is it funny all of those
different sorts of ways that you tell
stories and what stories are they can
come through and the words that you
choose as well as the melody the music
of the words so we're gonna split into
this breakout room again it'll be the
same breakout room because we're a small
group today which is cool
and
see
you
let's see join okay
so I think we're a breakout room again
everybody here can you start with
actually with Lea you're at the top of
the screen
a memorable thing that happened in 2019
probably the most significant for me was
I was a freelance website developer
after a long career is a big space
administrator I start over after a long
career in the database administrator I
became a website developer for the small
organizations in my very small town I
was good at it I enjoyed it I loved
working with people in the excitement of
their projects I was technically able to
deliver what they needed and it gave me
quite a pleasure to help people realize
their dreams what I discovered about
myself was I prefer to work with a team
with team members who could speak my
technical language and bounce ideas off
of each other which was one reason why I
started investigating becoming a data
scientist so I could leverage my 20
years experiences to DBA and enter the
data
Sanctus data engineering realm so the
significant part of all this was I was
able to step back from something that
was fun and I was good at but did not
make a lot of money from and take the
stand that I was going to follow my
dream of working with the team excellent
Thank You Leah
again you're listening to people if you
can just write down one word about what
you remember from what Leah just said
for example okay and now I'm going to
mute and Amane if you could go next
so beside my work in the automotive
industry I volunteer a lot and I was I
make the most biggest thing in 2019 if I
could I was able to get enough funds to
build the library from from often
orphans home and I put a lot of work on
it and I think that will be very
beneficial for them and it has always
been one of my big biggest interest to
to share knowledge and to make it more
to democratize it and to make it more
available for everyone and that took the
opportunity to do a robotic workshop and
that's where all the story of
programming started and yeah I'm very
proud of that we can see that too by the
way this is an example I'll just give
you this example of the spectacle this
isn't about your clothing in this way
but the way that you presented yourself
smiling we could see that you are proud
of it and they were happy about it and
that came across as part of your story
so I just want to point out when I see
things in or hear things with you all
but what is telling the story ok great
thank you
Magda
the most memorable situation I had last
year is it relates to myself and it
relates to to a person I work with for a
long time we have a very good first
personal and business relationship as
well and he's working for a company
where the company is in big challenges
because of the industry trends and he
was under pressure and during the years
I noticed that he is not in the
condition as not in the right condition
as a person to lead a team a department
a whole department and he is going to or
or actually he is in burnout and it is
really he was in a condition which was
really serious I would say and nobody
told him in what situation he is and I
was the person I said that I have to
tell him that he has to take a break and
he has to go to sabbatical and and get
together and talk to a coach so that was
I would say the most difficult time for
me to do it was solved so it went in a
very positive way but then after a few
months I also realized that I'm also in
the direction to get a burnout and and
then I have to take was a decision okay
what to do now so I also asked for an
expert to help me so I I didn't get to
that that point and when I I said that
I'm in burnout but I was very close to
that one and I'm really happy that I
could solve this obviously with the help
of the expert but also with my own help
and realization that situation and that
I have to change also in my work I think
that's excellent so what was and this
isn't to take your story lightly okay
but what what was good about that story
also was you started with somebody else
but you brought it to yours
self and and connected connected the
resolution of both and that made it a
clear story and that sense that that's a
good takeaway from that story thank you
thank you um lie smart only smart I'm
sorry if I'm setting things wrong in
stored remaining that happened in 2009
see it was when I just finished my post
graduation of sustainable tourism one of
the reason I had such to quickly as
possible two issues because I like to
travel a lot and we not just finish it
for my surprise I was invited to to give
it two courses and in the need to travel
to make these courses so for my surprise
I I could for the first time work and
travel and and talk about cinema tourism
and of course this happen because during
the course I made a lot of network
liking I mean doing now with capacity so
people know a lot about me even though I
never met these people before but they
know my story my inspiration so I think
it is really working like you really
talk about our stories to a bar because
we never know who can hear about us so
as the the master when I want to give it
here that we have we have to check other
portunus talk about ours what we're
doing because you never know who are
look around us with our stories Thank
You Liz Mar that's great and to that end
in the chat room this is a good
opportunity you know by the time we end
to for you all to share your email
addresses or your LinkedIn profiles and
to be able to stay in contact with each
other and say what else you might have
in common and what other collaborations
you could participate in with each other
not just learning a little bit about
storytelling on a Sunday afternoon thank
you
I Jamie
unmute yourself Jamie
I'm sorry so the the most memorable
thing that happened to me in 2019 was I
am I graduated college um I was my
backgrounds in web development so I am
my last course gave me many
opportunities to grow as a person and to
improve on my skills um and it gave me
the confidence that this is what I want
to do as a career choice and yeah now
I'm just starting to go in the into the
workforce and see what happens
that sounds very hopeful Jamie yeah it
is and and by the end of your speaking
right now I felt like you you felt that
more yourself as you were talking about
it or that's what came across as I'm
seeing you so excellent Thank You Emily
so one of the things that I got to do in
2019 was I travelled quite a bit and I
actually took up a new sport of rock
climbing
which was very exciting for me because I
climbed my first outdoor route in 2019
and after making that climb within two
to three weeks after that was when I
graduated from my nano degree with
Udacity so that was kind of a big push
for me to you know complete something in
sports and then also complete something
academically in the same year excellent
thank you wait
Jocelyn hi well I write some of my ideas
because English is my second language so
to 2019 was for me transitioning because
at the end of 2018
my granddaughter dies and it was a very
hard moment for my family and I and two
months later at the beginning of the
turn 18 my just dies due and I felt very
sad by the personal side of my life and
also by the professional life and I felt
that I was not good to finish my career
because the situation is a little hard I
felt sad Cybil I felt a little sad I
choose don't be I'm sorry
don't be said for forever
or her if I don't Jocelyn take take a
breath for a second okay yeah that's
okay make a precious to continue and
despite of my sadness I tried to focus
in my story and my work
and be okay be healthy for that I got an
intership oh the last on the beginning
of the 2018 and it was finished on June
also I try to focus in myself you know
to be more healthy and help my family
for the first time I move it out here in
Minnesota is not easy it's not a
traditional thing for example in United
States people when go to college and
move out but here is later also I apply
for several scholarships and hey I got
the Udacity scholarship at the end of
2018 and also right now they working in
my final work project and inspect edy
dies 2012 and was my will be my
graduation year and also be the
beginning of more exciting stories
because for knighting was a little bit
makes it Phyllis Jocelyn first of all
thank you thank you for sharing cuz it
sounds like 2019 was a challenging year
for me to pick for you to focus on right
now so thank you thank you forever very
much for sharing with that 2019 for me
was all about cancer which I had this
past year and all about learning how to
deal with it and getting through the
challenges of it basically and so I am
also hopeful jessalyn that 2020 will be
a much better year than 2019 was but it
was interesting to learn all about the
different things that you're assaulted
with with the modern treatments that are
really barbaric in cancer so anyway so
that was part of my story in 2019 I
wanted to thank you all first of all for
joining this class
it's we had a really small group and so
I'm really glad that we all got to share
with each other I wanted to know if any
of you have any questions as well and I
I'll go back to the slides in a moment
but just so we can all see each other
right now
any questions at all any try I have
question about the melody so sometimes
when I like especially when when I have
to present to like a management tool or
something like I have this choking voice
so as you as you were describing before
coming from here and and I don't know if
you have any any tips to when you get
into this situation how how you could
manage it and how to make sure that your
voice or your tone is back on track
right so a couple things one is one is
to be aware of how to breathe from your
diaphragm and diaphragm is is basically
the bottom of your lungs and that the
breath is coming from there there are a
couple ways to be aware of that one is
to hold your hands on top of your
diaphragm and to feel it expanding when
you breathe and to practice speaking
from their practice hearing your voice
from their coming up and out and feeling
the difference you you know that you
know what it sounds like when it's
coming from here and that tightness that
can be in your throat from there so one
thing is just be aware of it coming from
below and one of the best ways is to
keep your hands on your on that in the
practice mode and even when you're
giving a speech you can keep your hand
there as you're speaking if that's
possible
to make sure that you keep breathing
because part of talking from your throat
is that you're not breathing you're
you're breathing very shallowly one of
the other things that I like to
encourage people to do before they give
speeches or before they give interviews
for example is to go into the bathroom
before you go out to do this and to
raise your arms in the air as if you've
just won a race and to give your whole
body that sense of winning and
confidence and and that it's already
over basically before you've begun but
to get somatically so that physically
that feeling of confidence deep down and
to start from that place before you
start talking that's another way to also
sort of connect with your body and and
connect in a positive way any other
questions
Wonder Woman posed yes exactly people
get some nervous at the middle of that
species for example in my case I feel a
little bit insecure about my English
level so if I try to apply for example
and foreign a company and the interviews
is really good is in English so well
what will you suggest to keep calm I'm
comfy comfy in your English so one of
the things than this isn't just about
English okay this is when you're in an
interview situation the more that you
have practiced your stories that you
want to tell I usually suggest to people
to practice a six stories regardless of
their questions okay these same stories
can be used for different purposes the
same story might be used about teamwork
or leadership or failure
depending on how you tell the story
so the more that you know the stories
that you want to tell and the reasons
why you'd want to tell them I think that
goes to that that sort of confidence
when you're presenting yourself
basically if you know them inside and
out it's hard to get lost and hard to
get worried about it that being said
let's say it happens okay um and you're
in the middle of it and you forgot what
you're doing and and or you or you're
like a little worried about the English
not coming out right
it is totally acceptable to say just a
moment
and and gather yourself and have a pause
for yourself what's worse is to ramble
long and to be lost and to not know
where you're going anymore they'll do
not they'll remember that but you taking
a pause and gathering your thoughts and
getting it back together again they'll
forget that you took such a pause
that makes sense joseline yes thank you
anybody else have a question
okay let me just go back I'm going to
close out the breakout room stay with me
for a moment
you
Andrea had to manually click leave the
breakout room
it didn't happen automatically and you
are muted
Andrea you're muted
okay you can hear me now the closeout
room is going to take 20 seconds to
close for right now
sorry that's taking a moment
you
five seconds hopefully come back up
okay so I'm hoping that you all can see
can hear me now
you
and you hear me
yes okay great and can you see the
screen or are we seeing each other still
no no cannot see anything share one
second thank you
okay we are back with the shared screen
so I just this is just a reference for
you if you wanted to know more about
Aristotle or read the poetics and I
wanted to let you know also that there
are future seminars coming up on
February 5th in February 12th and you
can go to the career cut hub to sign up
for that and I just wanted to thank you
also for joining me today on a Sunday
and talking a bit about story and the
other thing I would say is you all have
access at different points you know in
different amounts to coaches and this is
a wonderful thing to go over with
coaches is you know how you're telling
your story how you're telling the about
you and getting yourself to a position
of feeling confident that it is a story
that people remember and so that's
that's the most important part of it of
course and thank you very much and I'll
see you around Udacity take care
thank you you're welcome you're welcome
thank you
you're quite less of you all over the
world take okay bye-bye